[Music]
burgers soda chips and chocolate all
sound like an amazing food choice
especially if you're hungry but
sometimes companies around the world
make weird flavors that we never ever
want to drive stick around to see the
weirdest Pringles we have ever seen and
you won't believe where they come from
hola
did you hear about our latest addition
to our family their richest espanol is
the perfect place for all you native
Spanish speakers out there don't speak
Spanish no problem
come on over this is the perfect place
to practice amazing facts interesting
people and funny pictures nos vemos ahi
green tea Kit Kats let's head to Japan
we're green tea Kit Kats are still a
huge topic of discussion we all know
cute cats are usually made of wafers and
absolutely covered with chocolate but
that's not how it works for every KitKat
out there
green tea Kit Kats are a popular
Japanese treat and as you might have
noticed they're not chocolaty they're
actually green if you've ever had green
tea you know it can sometimes taste
bitter
however when brewed correctly it's
actually pretty sweet which is why these
green tea Kit Kats are so good green tea
is also known to have many health
benefits although we can vouch that
those still exists when you combine it
with chocolate and wafers these KitKat
bars are so good
the demand for weird flavors is becoming
higher and higher in Japan and it's not
just the green tea that's a popular
weird flavor Japan has over 300 seasonal
and limited-edition kickout flavors out
there many of which you'd never be able
to get anywhere else in the world don't
know about you but we're on the verge of
booking a ticket to Japan and trying out
every single one of them if you ever do
head to Japan to try these delicious
treats stop at Kit Kat chocolate or a
Nestle's official Kit Kat store where
you can find many more flavors of this
weird chocolate bar fish and chip gelato
as much as we know that fish and chips
are aniconic meal in the UK it's not the
only country known for this dish
Australia is also the land of fish and
chips but Australians seem to take the
flavor to a new level
let us introduce you to the fish and
chip gelato sure it might sound crazy
and we can't blame you if you feel
grossed out the
scream flavor took five months to
develop and was worked on by Italian
flavor scientists who make and test the
majority of gelato flavors well even
though it was tested the fishing ship
flavor is a hit or miss for many and
according to a few reviews that taste is
far from fishy and you can barely taste
the salt and vinegar in fact a lot of
people claim it's absolutely delicious
and kind of sweet but you have to admit
that a gelato with a fish and chip
flavor doesn't sound that appealing at
first even looking at the actual poster
for one of the Australian marketplaces
that sells this weird gelato flavor
doesn't look appetizing but for some
reason we're desperate to try this one
would you ever try a fish and chip ice
cream flavor or is that taking it a bit
too far lamb and mint Walker's do you
love snacking on chips
we bet there are a few flavors out there
that you wouldn't even dare to try let's
leave Australia alone for a minute and
head to the UK British food can
sometimes seem strange to the outsiders
you've probably heard of Walker's chips
before they've actually had several
limited edition flavor versions that
didn't sound as good we still can't get
on board with the whole prawn cocktail
thing but lamb and mint sounds just as
bizarre roast lamb and mint are popular
recipes for advanced chefs but we're not
sure how that would work with chips
according to reviews it tastes exactly
as you think a potato chip covered with
a roasted lamb and mint flavor if you
love Sunday roasts or barbecues you'd
absolutely love this flavor along with
lamb and mince British chips offers some
other questionable flavors like pork
sausage and English mustard sweet cured
ham and pickle and even oyster and
vinegar Chardonnay wine vinegar is our
personal favorite from the bizarre
collection but lamb and mint sound just
as odd we all know British people have
an interesting taste in food but we
can't ever imagine and join some of
these what's the weirdest ship flavor
you've ever tried let us know in the
comments
banana split Oreo you probably have at
least one friend who's obsessed with
Oreos ask them if they've ever tried
this bizarre flavor it's time to cross
the pond and head over to the good ole
USA and dive into America's most popular
cookies with some of the weirdest play
ever Oreos have been taking over the
world since 1912 it's pretty hard to not
love this chocolate cookie with a
delicious filling everyone eats Oreos in
their own special way but we're not sure
everyone would approve of the banana
split Oreo this flavor of cookie was
released twice first in 2008 and again
in 2013 on the outside the cookie has
one chocolate and one normal side and on
the inside it has a half strawberry half
banana filling unfortunately a lot of
people haven't had a good opinion on
this cookie due to it's a weird banana
taste if you've ever experienced
anything with artificial banana flavor
you'll know that it's never as good as
it claims to be
maybe it's the overwhelming mix of
flavors that just don't really vibe
together however we know that in reality
chocolate cookies strawberries and
bananas would be incredibly delicious
together what do you think is it a gay
or an A for this weird and colorful
banana split Oreo honey soy chicken
chips how do you like your chips you
prefer them salty or sweet these odd
sounding chips belong to an Australian
company called the Red Rock deli known
for combining unusual ingredients and
giving your typical chips brand-new
flavors green chilly and coriander is
our personal favourites but we just
can't imagine what honey soy chicken
tips would actually taste like the soy
and honey would make them sweet and
we're not sure if that would be such a
good idea they're advertised as gourmet
chips that are slow-cooked in sunflower
oil and seasoned with subtle and sweet
flavors of soy sauce chicken and honey
we've just got used to people putting
ketchup on their popcorn and the sound
of sweet chips doesn't seem any better
than that
but we bet there are many people out
there who can't get enough of this sweet
tasting snack of course they're not the
only odd chips that come from Australia
you've probably heard that the country
adores Vegemite which is one of the
spreads many consider to be absolutely
horrible tasting it's impossible to even
describe the actual bitter taste of it
but perhaps those who don't like
Vegemite itself would actually love
these Vegemite chips if you had to
choose between honey soy chicken or
veggie might flavored chips which one
would you go for we vote for honey soy
chicken Pepsi whites we all know Japan
is known for experimenting with food
but we were still surprised when we
heard about this Pepsi has some weird
flavors but nothing prepared us for
Pepsi white we have no idea what this
would actually taste like but remember
that it's a carbonated drink Pepsi
release a white colored version of
everyone's favorite soda and turned it
into yogurt flavor yes you heard that
right
it tastes like yogurt in 2008 Pepsi
Japan released a limited version of
Pepsi white a yogurt flavored soda the
idea behind it came because Japanese
consumers began to change their diet and
stepped away from unhealthy drinks in
order to complement the health-conscious
customers popsie created this yogurt
flavored soda the product definitely got
attention the cloudy color might be a
little off-putting but the taste of this
Pepsi isn't actually yoghurt it comes
off as lemony with a hint of vanilla
which is understandable considering
you're still drinking soda some even
consider it has a sweet taste if you
find that surprising you really
shouldn't be because Pepsi Japan also
produce products like ice cucumber Pepsi
we really need to go to Japan and take a
week to experience every possible odd
food flavor they have
in 2008 Pepsi slogan was called
something for everyone but we're not
sure it would apply to their yogurt
flavored drink bacon days it might be
weird but we promise you'll love it
bacon days originates from the US and it
was created by a company called Jay
Andes foods this company produces bacon
flavored items that include anything
from food to lip balms but a bacon
flavored mayonnaise we're not sure how
to feel about that America has a long
lasting relationship with bacon and
we've seen products like bacon soda and
even Cologne so we really shouldn't be
surprised that there's a bacon
mayonnaise out there but we never
thought that this Mayo is actually
completely vegetarian the founders
combined the elements of vegetables that
give the same smoky savory and salty
taste just like bacon does and believe
it or not this product is also kosher
certified it honestly sounds like heaven
on earth this company creates a lot of
bacon products that originally started
as a complete joke are even in April
Fool's prank but because the u.s. is
pretty much in love with bacon they're
able to sell just about any
including the awesome-looking bacon A's
in fact their bacon live bomb had a
waiting list of 5,000 people and the
product wasn't even made yet because it
was just a joke at first have you ever
tried bacon A's let us know what you
thought about it because we're buying 20
jars next time we see it in the store
elderflower of Fanta Pepsi is not the
only one coming up with weird flavors in
other countries if you visited Eastern
European countries like Bulgaria and
Hungary before 2006 you probably saw a
blue looking Fanta sold in stores
although the color looks way too intense
miss Fanta is made of lemon and
elderflower it's called shoukata and
it's a soda lover's favourite limited
edition drink the blend is completely
unique and it's one of the most
refreshing drinks ever even though the
original flavor name doesn't make it
sound that appealing if you love soda
you'll love this the first fancy flavor
Fanta orange came out in 1955 and since
then the company made over 90 flavors
worldwide some are limited-edition
others have been discontinued and some
sound completely weird one of those is
definitely the lemony elderflower Fanta
others include Jamaica's apple lime
Fanta or finland strawberry twist which
has a strawberry and kiwi taste if
you're really desperate to try
elderflower fans fi can't find it
anywhere near you if you should step by
IKEA and grab one of their elderflower
syrup although it's not the same as the
carbonated drink it'll give you a pretty
good impression of what to expect with
elderflower Fanta taste our question is
would you prefer the elderflower Fanta
or the yogurt flavored Pepsi white our
vote goes to elderflower Fanta black fun
burgers you must be pretty hungry by now
and unfortunately things are about to
get worse let's talk about fast food
more specifically the black bun burgers
that originated in Japan but can now be
found all around the world
Japan is clearly the winner of the
weirdest food flavors because we're not
done yet with exploring the amazing food
of this country in 2014 Burger King
Japan came out with Halloween themes
black burgers that included black
cheese and sauce which was made with
charcoal these sandwiches don't look
appealing at all and it looks like they
leave a big mess after you're done with
them
according to Burger King Japan's
marketing team this was a way to gain
attention the team explained that their
ad budgets are too small for any
promotional campaigns so instead they
decided to come up with something else
they really did a good job because the
black sandwiches speak for themselves
and McDonald's joined in on the craze
shortly after and the taste it tasted
exactly like a regular Burger King
burger and without a trace of anything
that would give away its color they
clearly knew what they were doing as you
can find these burgers just about
anywhere what do you think is it a yay
or nay for black burgers from Japanese
Burger King see you eat Pringles but
Japan is not the only country that's
known for exotic food flavors the most
bizarre tasting products we could find
belong to China they were seaweed
Pringles if you don't like the taste of
seaweed you probably won't like this but
it's definitely a snack you have to try
at least once in your life see you eat
Pringles are green but they are still
regular potatoes covered in seaweed
we're not entirely sure how a feeling
that might sound to you but we'll try to
explain the flavor the best way we can
you might think these crisps would be
way too salty because of the seaweed but
the truth is they really lowered the
levels of salt on this one each chip
even has bits of sugary coating which
means it's a lot sweeter than you would
expect they're also not as thin as your
regular seaweed snacks in fact many
claim they don't taste like seaweed at
all they almost taste like regular
Pringles if you do want to enhance the
seaweed taste
we recommend grabbing actual seaweed and
placing it on top and if you're looking
for more weird Pringles from China you
should check out the crab or grilled
shrimp flavor we can't tell you what
they taste like
but let's just say we'd stick to TV
Pringles if we had to choose between the
three what was the weirdest food you've
ever tried let us know in the comments
for more videos like this one check out
10 foods you'll never buy again after
knowing how they are made see you next
time
[Music]